Jordan would seems ready to tell her
side of the story in the Tristan
Thompson cheating scandal
it looks like Jordan is going public on
Jada Pinkett Smith's read.table talk
after the Kardashian family cut ties
with her yeah guys the 21 year old model
shared a video of herself walking to the
infamous red table on her Instagram Live
Tuesday et can confirm Jordans episode
is set to air Friday March 1st on
Facebook watch a source tells ET quote
the Kardashians are upset with Jordans
red tabletalk interview and feel like
she should be focusing more on healing
her relationship privately with the
family or Kylie than talking about it
publicly okay so the bigger issue here
Jordan who appeared on Keeping Up with
the Kardashians and life of Kylie
reportedly signed a nondisclosure
agreement that prohibits her from
speaking publicly about the reality TV
family's private lives and personal
drama even if she's in the drama right
right Jordan could be crossing the line
with the Kardashians by giving an
interview if Jordan violated the NDA
during her sit-down she could face a
pricey a lawsuit I would not want to go
against them in court that sounds
horrible our source adds the
kardashian-jenner family quote just wish
her way of dealing with it was done in a
different way if Jordan doesn't handle
this the right way any possible hope of
her being back in with the family or
Kylie will be gone now remember this guy
wait wait Jordan was is doing an
interview with red tape will talk to
Jada pinkett-smith about her cheating
his name is Jason Lee from Hollywood
unlocked and you might remember he's the
one who broke the alleged cheating story
so he posted again about the red
tabletalk update and kardashian besties
Larsa Pippen she was quick to get in the
comments of his post writing quote can't
wait to see which version of her story
she tells hope it's the same she told at
Khloe Kardashian when she checked her so
things are getting Messier than ever and
we'll Jordan ever be able to mend her
relationship with the family especially
Kylie after a decades-long friendship I
don't know how
I know it's a good question I really
thought they were right or dies they've
been best friends since eighth grade
when Jada and Will Smith's son Jaden
introduced them we met through a mutual
friend
she grew up she's known Jaden like her
whole life and then I met him like in
middle school and like they were best
friends they still are it makes sense
that Jordan would open up about the
cheating allegation on red tabletalk
given her close relationship with the
Smith family yeah and it might be a safe
place for her to open up Jada told et
this month that for her those read.table
talks are really all about seeing where
other people are coming from there have
been times where it's been one-on-one
with people and you have this way of
figuring out hope we can do it mm-hmm
and you can do it right what how do you
know how to get into people's souls um I
think it's just really the empathy like
really feeling people mm-hmm
you know it's just like when you're in a
conversation you just is that heart
connect you know what I mean it's not
it's it's not um it's a it's a
conversation of like trying to just get
more understanding and build love and
connection I love connecting to people
there is nothing more pleasurable to me
than sitting at a table looking in
someone's eyes and making an energetic
connection so I know a lot of people are
talking about Jordan's career and will
it be over and I think there's a lot of
heat being put on Jordan and I think we
owe it to her to hear her side of the
story everyone deserves that opportunity
absolutely without passing judgment and
obviously with this new publicity it can
be good or bad for her but let's just
hear her out first obviously when it
comes to Chloe and Tristan we know that
they called it quits but there seems to
be a double standard in this scandal
Tristan seems to be continuing with his
life and career with no real
consequences so let's just keep that in
mind guys
I like that course now shortly after
news broke that Jordan and Tristan were
seen making out at a party a source told
et the model is quote devastated in
believe how her entire world has flipped
upside down so fast
Ollis drama of course comes after Chloe
and Tristan dated for two years and this
is only ten months after the NBA Pro
made headlines when he reportedly
cheated on Chloe with multiple women
while she was pregnant with their
daughter true oh my gosh we can't wait
to see where this whole Jordan sit-down
takes us as the story continues to
develop we'll have all the latest so be
sure to subscribe to ET in the meantime
I met Holly underscore Stevens and I met
Courtney underscore Tessa no.5 for now
guys
[Music]